starting today one of the nation's
busiest airports is using thermal
cameras to spot passengers with a fever
all in hopes of identifying travelers
with the coronavirus los angeles
international airport is launching the
first in the country pilot program and
it begins with cameras scanning fliers
at the Tom Bradley International
Terminal but the researchers warn that
temperature checks alone will not catch
every passenger with the virus Kris Van
Cleave gives us a look fever
hunting thermal cameras now live at LAX
the airport is testing how well three
different systems spot passengers with a
temperature of 100 point 4 or higher as
they pass by fliers flagged for fever
will be tested again by a medical
professional on the spot our ability to
spot folks that are exhibiting kovat
symptoms is so critical to stopping its
spread to ensuring that people can
travel safely but harvard researchers
warned temperature screenings could miss
two thirds of coronavirus cases and this
reopening document from airports and
airlines says the screenings have not
proved to be 100% effective but can play
a useful role in reassuring the
traveling public
lax interim CEO Justin herb a chi isn't
this just safety theater this is not
meant to catch everybody it's just
another layer of protection that we have
on top of many other layers to try to do
all we can to make sure that our
airports are clean healthy and safe
Qatar Airways resumes lax service next
week its flight attendants are wearing
head-to-toe PPE but its CEO calls
pre-flight temperature checks the
science doesn't prove that you need to
do temperature check but we do see
arrows pain field was the first u.s.
airport to launch temperature checks
Frontier Airlines started screening
passengers at boarding this month for
CBS this morning Kris Van Cleave
Washington all right we will see if it
works there Kris Van Cleave reporting
from the Tom Bradley International
Terminal in Los Angeles